[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish the benefits
of healthy eating are Bountiful the
downside we often assume though is
sacrificing flavor but not in this
episode today we're exploring Chef's
healthy and delectable dishes from beef
hummus in Los Angeles to mapo tofu in
Brooklyn We Begin right here in
Manhattan where a James Beard
award-winning Chef is focused on
bringing nutritious food to his
neighborhood
without Harlem I wouldn't be Chef JJ to
Chef JJ Johnson feeding this community
is the Pinnacle of his culinary career
even as a fast casual takeout King how
important was it to open field trip here
my goal was to show people that black
and brown communities want health
conscious food or better conscious
eating and why not it be in the heart
you know between 115th and 116 Michael
Boulevard that's the heart of Harlem
let's show the world that and let the
people show the world that that was very
important to me that's the idea behind
field trip and its menu an invitation to
connect communities through a single
Source let's talk rice because rice is
such a fixture now it's the base of
field trip our slogan is Rice's culture
and you'll see that reflected in our
dishes at field trip all the bowls you
eat are influenced by the rice grain so
this is southeast Asia this is a our
veggie bowl that has coconut yogurt
broccoli jollof rice is a mixture of
India in West Africa you have the
seafood gumbo our hot honey plantains
shrimp bowl with some coconut sticky
rice green curry our famous crab Pockets
that people will fight you for if we run
out our dragon fruit lemonade some rice
krispie treats sake I brought it all for
you but field trip opened just eight
months before the pandemic shut down New
York City and with it Johnson thought
his dream
you know I was always worried you know
me I'm a fighter I'm just gonna always
go there's not many things that could
like really stop me in my tracks like
I'm gonna figure out a way around it he
figured it out when he realized his
community needed something more than
just home delivery
the first call came in and it was an
elderly woman and I went I delivered
that order to that lady and I'm by the
elevator she shouted Sarah Sarah can you
come back I need help I need help and I
thought about my grandmother and she was
just basically like no can you help me
move my oxygen tank
that's where it started then it was like
can you feed my cat you were like almost
full time
and then I said well where's your
caregiver and she said well no
caregivers could come to our house
because of covid it was that and a
conversation with his wife that pushed
him to the next level my wife came home
as a nurse
1 30 in the morning saying I didn't eat
any food and I said well how can you go
the whole day without eating there was
no time to even think about it and that
moment was like okay I need to do
something and of course I've set food to
her hospital that was my first
realization of like okay now I know who
field trip is now I know our purpose and
we have our marching orders and let's
keep marching born on Long Island
Johnson was raised in the Pennsylvania
Poconos and spent a lot of his early
childhood prepping food in the kitchen
my mom would drop us off to my
grandparents house in the morning she
would go to work my dad be long gone and
when I grew up I thought they were my
great aunts but they were my great great
aunts
that were Puerto Rican and they were my
grandma Sous chefs
so from the beginning of the morning
they'd be cooking
lunchtime they be cooked they'd be
making their own stocks so I would be
peeling carrots or onions or celery or
washing rice in the sink for them you
know standing on a milk crate or a step
stool he was hooked and later went on to
graduate from the prestigious Culinary
Institute of America soon after earning
a position in the kitchen at New York's
famed Tribeca Grill where was I going to
live I couldn't afford rent so I had to
call my aunt Jeannie and my aunt Estelle
they lived together first day she sat
down with me in her apartment so I'm
gonna tell you one thing New Yorker make
you or break you
you figure it out his big break came
when he was tapped by chef and
entrepreneur Alexander Smalls as
executive chef of the Cecil and mintons
Harlem's historic jazz club after six
years in fine dining he opted out so I
was like okay
I need to take a risk I don't know if it
was the right time my wife was pregnant
we're about to have twins right so
there's never the right time when you
want to be an entrepreneur and spread
your wings Johnson is continuing to
spread his wings you do realize that
you're doing what
so many other restaurants are not all I
can say is praise the Lord
is that sunk in that you're doing the
what some people say is the impossible
it sinks in at times and other times I'm
just going yeah constant motion
consummotion and I think the times I
bring you
to happiness
is when your 95 year old grandfather
says to you you're doing good kid right
those are the moments where you take a
step back and go
okay
this is great
coming up we head to the Golden State to
meet a chef creating comfort food
without the calories this is the dish
[Music]
eating clean and cooking clean is Chef
Fernando Darin's Mantra as our Dana
Jacobson found out the menu at his
restaurant mother tongue in Los Angeles
mirrors that
it doesn't feel like a traditional
restaurant nourishing the mind and the
body that's the intent of mother tongue
the patio here is probably my favorite
executive chef Fernando darine says it's
a concept built into the restaurant
which occupies the top floor of the
social and fitness club hymat a name
that means the feeling of home the name
of the restaurant mother Tong was a very
easy reflection of what highmat is we
wanted to take all these dishes from
around the world and transforming it
into our own mother tongue
simply put it's comfort food from around
the world but all made using nutritional
ingredients without sacrificing taste a
challenge Chef Fernando as he's known at
mother tongue embraced I took this
project because of the challenge and
because this reflects my lifestyle as
well I like to eat clean I like to cook
clean and the food that it's on that
menu is a reflection of that take mother
Tong's version of a traditional bread
service Pita alongside three colorful
and flavorful dips you can mix the
colors and you can make a painting if
you like there's a syrian-based walnut
mahamara
oh I love this one a beat hummus and an
avocado and tarragon moose with the
antioxidant spirulina on top they all
have like very distinct flavors but like
they got your mouth going along with
health there's also a focus on
sustainability like in the mother tongue
lamb we use a not-so popular cut the
neck which is very flavorful and a very
sustainable thing cured for two days
roasted for five to six hours then
shredded before being served in a
papayote it feels good to be using the
cuts not everyone thinks about using it
that lamb is like melt in your mouth
each offering also maintains a focus on
comfort and multi-ethnicity the
Brazilian Mojica a seafood stew served
with rice toasted Yucca flour herbs and
onions fetowa a cousin of paella made
with lobster shrimp and roasted Citrus
all on top of a thin new noodle instead
of rice the noodles get crispy yeah so
there's a lot of texture going on the
cultural Fusion reflective of Chef
Fernando who grew up in Brazil with an
Italian Heritage the Italian food that I
know is not the Italian food that is in
Italy right it's an adaptation with
Brazilian ingredients and this is what I
love not to get too attached to the
recipe the right ingredient itself open
your mind and that's when true
creativity can flow since he was a kid
Chef Fernando has had his hands in the
kitchen learning the cooking Basics from
his grandmother should make me help out
and she would make me stir the polenta
which I hated it because it was just
like for hours stirring that polenta it
started all very very young but you
didn't think this is going to be my
future in cooking when you were young no
no when did that change for you I think
it it changed when I moved to Los
Angeles I came here just to stay for a
few months honestly and I knew this guy
that introduced me to this great chef
called Eric Greenspan two years later I
was his sous chef one door started to
open and another door another door and
then I was like
15 years later I'm still here well he
may call it an unintended career it's
combined perfectly with the one he
thought he'd have as a musician playing
guitar there are so many chefs that we
talk to that music is their other
passion is there something there is
there it's very connected I feel there's
a very similar thing about conducting an
orchestra and conducting a kitchen are
you ready steam the way that people work
together it's very similar I'm even
thinking in a recipe it's like I need a
little more violin or I need a little
more spice I use that a lot that analogy
I say Disney's a little eq'ing like a
little bit more bass or a little bit
more lids
fats and oils yeah are like the base
and highs vinegars and lemon the right
combination Harmony something mother
tongue strives for in each item on the
menu oh my gosh it's ever popular
rizzoni a perfect example orzo Quorum
puree and strachatella cheese with black
truffle shaved on top it's a very simple
dish but I honestly think that
Simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication another mother tongue
Mantra played out in dessert this yeah
this is wonderful
um which for us was an Indian inspired
carrot cake pudding with cardamom cream
and pistachios I'm going to go back to
the menu because we started talking
about the challenge of creating it but
how much fun did you have in creating
the menu it's probably the most fun part
of opening a restaurant I like to go and
I like to watch the table can be a
sounds a little creepy sounds a little
creepy but I don't do that often but I
like to see you know people's reactions
and probably the most interesting
reaction that I ever got in my cooking
career really because I feel like here I
was able to translate my personality to
its fullest to the menu and people
acknowledge when something is true you
know something's not fake the menu here
is truthful to what I am
all
after the break we meet a chef turned
four-time best-selling author you're
watching the dish
from Humble Asian and Australian Roots
grew a force of nature in both the
culinary and Publishing World Hedy
McKinnon met up with me at a farmer's
market to show how fresh produce is key
to her cooking
so I mean what I love is like really
focusing on everyday vegetables walk
through Hedy McKinnon's local farmers
market what are we looking for we're
looking for broccoli okay and you get a
feast for the eyes now that's a good
piece of broccoli sense for the soul we
still have Peaches I think I'm gonna get
some peaches and a feeling that even in
the heart of Brooklyn you can taste a
bit of her ancestral Homeland
this food writer and self-described home
cook wants to show people the basics of
Chinese and Asian cooking without all
the fuss
it's the basis of her cookbook to Asia
with love and the reason we're sharing a
seed at the table when we ate my mom
would call us to the table with the
words
eat rice eat rice it's like that in many
Asian cultures the rice is the sacred
ingredient on the table and at her mom's
table Precision was key so you had to
have a good command of your chopsticks
and we would eat every single rice
kernel before we left the table so how
am I doing you're doing okay dig in
there
and dig in we did to a traditional
Cantonese banquet based on her mother's
recipes and McKinnon's vegetarian habit
some of these things are exactly how my
mom would make like this is actually my
mom's recipe the map of tofu it's a
vegan version you know the original
version has the ground pork so my mum
actually started helping me veganize all
vegetarian eyes the dishes that she knew
I loved the potato and chive omelette is
naturally vegetarian anyway it was one
of her quick meals growing up and it's
so comforting potatoes and eggs that run
through a lot of culture that's like
scrambled eggs and hash browns basically
right there is also a Japanese inspired
miso roasted eggplant stir-fried
potatoes with salt and vinegar a nod to
British chips green beans dressed with
fermented soybeans my youngest actually
says I want to stop but I can't when he
eats those green beans every mother's
dream exactly and another Asian staple
bok choy a dish I call restaurant greens
so you know it's beautiful by the way
isn't it beautiful and my mum taught me
how to make it with she puts a little
bit of oil and sugar in the water that
you blanch it and it just keeps the
greenness so the vibrancy of the color
is really important the other thing
about these types of dishes you know a
reflection of me growing up in two
countries and kind of bringing together
those two influences you know the third
culture that third culture notion came
after what McKinnon calls an identity
crisis I was born in Sydney Australia I
grew up being very much caught between
the two cultures you know at home my mum
built this very Chinese household we
spoke Cantonese at home we ate like this
every night we celebrated she lit
incense every morning at her altar to
pay respects to her elders and we
celebrated all the Customs but as soon
as I left the front all I wanted to be
Australian did you feel that sense of
Shame almost yeah I didn't want people
to ever hear me speaking Cantonese I
didn't even want to admit that I could
speak a different language until I
started cooking which was really only 10
years ago I really
fell into a career in food and it was
like reclaiming you know who I am
reclaiming my culture and so the recipe
is here that you see before you are like
me saying I'm really proud of who I am
and as a mother that I can bring that to
my children McKinnon's interest in food
has taken her through family community
and neighborhood themes of her popular
cookbooks and articles she's written
over the last decade it even LED Hong
Kong Restaurant Vita to ask her to
create a vegetarian menu they didn't
want a traditional Chinese menu but I
got to do things like a soba noodle
salad with my ginger scallion oil which
is what I call my mother sauce it was an
incredible experience going there and
being asked to do that validating I
would assume I felt like it was imposter
syndrome when I was there because I was
in a kitchen training proper chefs I
don't call myself a chef I'm a home cook
I didn't go to cooking school or
anything but more importantly about that
trip wow it was incredible to go back to
the smells and the sounds that I
remember from childhood which drives her
desire for those outside the culture to
access it it resonated with so many
people and people felt comforted by the
stories and to me that's all I want out
of all the food and all the stories that
I create is for people to feel that
Comfort yeah this is what I call Umami
bomb it's an Umami bomb the kind of
comfort that can only be created around
a table by blending the old with the new
there seems to be a bit of
rebelliousness
these recipes yes The Dumpling chapter
it's I was very proud of this Michelle
it's dumplings by the season so the idea
behind it is you could go to the market
whatever vegetables are in season and
you could turn that into a dumpling
anything you want I was like yeah
beetroot that could go at a dumpling
brussels sprouts that could go on a
dumpling I do a lot of things like that
which are not traditional it is probably
my way of rebelling against the
tradition that my mum presented to me so
it's fun it's you yeah it's me
and I just wanted to show you oh you're
good I
don't know I was so impressed
here we go there
we go cheers
[Laughter]
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Michelle
Miller we'll see you next time for
another helping of the dish
this episode of the dish is sponsored by
Prudential plan invest insure retire
with Prudential